one of the things about structure that I
found that sort of changed more than
anything for me because I didn't realize
this for the first 10 or 15 years that I
was a consultant and lecturer and that
is I always thought of plot structure
meaning it was the sequence of events
and the things that happened and that's
sort of externally so this need and it
is it is a plot structure and there are
certain key things that need to happen
at 25% and 50% and 75 but the Revelation
to me was when I realize that the inner
Journey the character takes also has a
structure and it's exactly the same
structure you
cannot judge your
character in fact you have to think of
yourself as your character's attorney oh
wow you have to plead your case or the
case of the character to the audience
you can't do that if you're judging the
character um and I took that with acting
and I also took that into my writing as
well you know everybody is coming from a
place where they think they're doing the
right thing we as the
audience jump onto the screen and become
the protagonist in the story and a good
story has some sort of a fantasy and it
doesn't have to be a positive fantasy
that we want to explore in our life so
we skin jump and we are Elliot riding is
bicycle with ET and it flies you know
and that is like one of those moments
where if you were to turn the camera on
the audience and watch what watch the
audience they would all be just
Overjoyed because we're all Elliot in
that scene for that moment and if we're
looking at a movie that's a um we're we
can become Indiana Jones and do the
amazing adventure thing and we basically
jump from the audience onto the screen
which means we need a character to jump
into and a good story is about a
character that fulfills some sort of uh
dream fulfillment some sort of fantasy
the audience has and a the reason why a
film is a hit is because it ends up
hitting the dream fulfillment elements
of a lot of people and so if you can
figure out the Zeitgeist of what the
audience what people are dreaming about
right now that's that thing that's going
to pull us onto the screen the first
thing you have to understand about
dialogue is that it's got to be
connected to the character's desire line
in the scene in other words if a
character has an objective an intention
in the scene the dialogue has to match
that intention and what I see a lot of
times especially with Exposition and
information is that a character is
saying all that information and you can
tell that it's really The Writer's
objective in other words the writer
wants to wants the audience to know this
information because they think okay the
audience needs to know this and this and
this and this so the character is going
to say this and this and this and this
and that doesn't work because scenes and
dialogue are about a character's
intention in the scene everything a
character
says is matched to what that desire line
is the device by which we make a
character sympathetic is to show their
wounds because as human beings we're not
going to be interested in good looking
perfect people who are Mak making a lot
of money and they're great and
everything they do who gives a we want
to see people that we can identify with
because that's not us we've got problems
right I've got problems right I want to
see my problems and somebody else with
problems dealing with problems okay and
you can say well you know a show like um
like Riverdale doesn't do that but they
do and there's fantasy shows uh
absolutely fantasy shows where where
that's not the case but most of the time
you do want to see a wound
that's what likeability really means oh
they're like me they're screwed up they
don't have it all together wish I did
maybe they'll get it together a story
there's a connection where between the
parts this happens which leads to that
happening which makes it ironic when
this other thing happens uh there's a
connection between the parts uh another
way I can put it is if I can take your
protagonist out of your script and put a
completely different one in and maybe
with a couple of tweaks it works just as
well you have a situation my friend not
a story interesting I shouldn't be able
to do that if you're telling a story if
I were to take your protagonist out it
would no longer work a story is unique
to your protagonist there's something
there's a unique Journey a reason why
you the master of the universe here has
put this character on this
path there's something in that character
that you've chosen to do this particular
plot in order to bring out something in
them and so if I can put just another
character in it it works just as well
that's not a situation that's not
testing anything specific to the
character it's just an arbitrary
situation that you put a character you
put someone into and that's what most
people do I mean that's the way a lot of
us start it's it's not you know I don't
mean to um it doesn't mean that it's not
a fixed situation I think one of the
biggest mistakes is jumping into
something that's not going to teach us
anything so it doesn't matter to the
story but you think it's
cool right so understanding that those
first few pages are about the setup
right so this is this is me gathering
information about the character about
the world about you know I'm going to
start making assumptions about what's
going to happen I'm not looking for the
inciting incident on page one but I am
looking for things that are intentional
and things that are going to help me
understand at least who this character
is so that's why you'll see a lot of
action films open with an action scene
because you're teaching me the skills
that this protagonist has you're
teaching me that they know how to fight
they're usually the good the good guy
they're usually the winners or whatever
other information that you need me to
know and so now when the inciting
incident does happen and they say you're
going to have to go off and save the
world I believe they can do it because
you've already shown me that they can
writing is a process of questions that
like if I could there's a couple of
things that I wish I could like get
tattooed on the inside of people's
eyelids that they knew think in scenes
and writing is a process of questions
it's not a thing you have to fill out
it's not a form that you have to fit
into writing is a question is always a
process of having something it could be
just I want to write a western or I want
to talk about how Love Hurts or I want
to talk about about how love saved my
life whatever it is that you start with
then you start to ask questions how am I
going to tell this story am I going to
tell it through a character who gets it
or a story who doesn't get it everything
is going to be a choice every question
that you ask if you write down that
question how am I going to tell this
story who is the main character
everything is a question and those
questions are who is it about what do
they want why can't they get it what do
they do about that why doesn't that work
how does end those six questions
basically will help you write anything
transformation in a story is a key
element and whether it comes through
your main character or your main
character changing um everyone else it
doesn't matter it's just that
transformation is actually the purpose
of a story it's actually the purpose of
a story because the reason we tell
stories is to actually understand
ourselves better and that Insight is a
transformation for us now that you have
sort of uh loaded up your with equipment
and reassurance and you know where
you're going you know what you want
you've faced your fear you've been
reassured now it's time to get up and go
and uh when I was working for the movie
studios especially for Disney they
talked about this like an airplane
taking off and they said you've spent
all this time in what they call the
First Act the first three or four or
five movements
uh those first
steps you've loaded the plane up and
you've fueled the plane and you've told
everybody to Belt their seat belts and
you know all the safety things now get
the wheels up and get the plane in the
air so uh this is the feeling of lifting
up that you get when all the preparation
is ready and now we're going into that
new world or special world as Joseph
Campbell calls it he says every story he
ever looked at seems to take place in
Two Worlds either environments or states
of being uh two different states of
conditions so now we're going to really
launch into that special world and this
is a big turning point in a story uh
that signals the audience all the prep
is done now we're really going for it
and the audience likes that and they
feel a nice lift there and sometimes
it's backed up by change in the music or
the change in the energy of the scene to
say we're leaving
Kansas we're leaving the Ordinary World
and now we're going someplace very very
different and
exotic